hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 class as always my name is Caleb
Denby and I will be your driver on this
journey to 2000s today's lecture is
going to be focused around a particular
opening which a lot of people sometimes
think these classes aren't the most
useful as the the general topic classes
but I think focusing on one opening even
if it's not an opening you're familiar
with or an opening you play can be very
very useful because it introduces you to
new plans and ideas that you might not
be familiar with and really at the end
of the day chess is is the same game no
matter what opening you play and so
learning more ideas is always going to
be helpful
now this opening in particular is a
variation in the nimzo-indian defense so
how many people are familiar with the
nimzo-indian defense hopefully all of
you okay well let's put it on the board
really quick starts with d4 Knight f6 c4
e6 Knight c3 and then the move that
denotes the nimzo-indian is Bishop b4 so
black attacks this knight on c3
developing the ship to a very far
advanced square and generally in the
nimzo-indian the big imbalance that is
created is after this Bishop captures
this knight on c3 white kind of has a
structural weakness with this b-pawn
coming to c3 and meanwhile black is
giving up the bishop pair quite early on
so if you notice this move is attacking
this knight and pinning it to the king
and this loosens white's control over
the e4 square and so the variation I
want to talk about is a variation you've
probably seen before it's been coming to
this class for a while
it's the f3 NIMS oh this is my personal
favorite against the nimzo-indian you
play f3 simply controlling the square
once again and threatening to expand
quite early on in the center now this
isn't the most popular way to respond to
the nihms oh and black actually does
have quite a few options here so how
many of you have played either side of
this opening before anybody
alright Brian a little bit so what are
some some various options for black here
it doesn't matter if you've played it or
not before what moves kind of come to
mind against this f3 f3 move if you're
the black player here what can you do
yeah
d5 is one of the most natural moves and
this is going to be a big topic of
today's lecture is what happens after
people play d5 I think this is the most
natural move and so a lot of people a
lot of class players in particular and
even players going above 2000 when
they're creating their opening
repertoire they'll say ok the f3 names
Oh nobody really plays that I'll just
play the most natural d5 my opponent
wants to control this square I'll attack
this square and not give it to them and
that's kind of all they really look at
and so that's gonna be the main subject
of most of the games today because
players with the black pieces that I've
faced have historically played this
opening very very poorly and I've played
some of the easiest games of chess of my
life in this opening I kind of just do
the same thing every game and it seems
to be working pretty well this like I
said this is one of my favorite
variations and so I wanted to talk about
what they're doing wrong in this most
natural d5 opening and how strong
players will play it differently so
that's going to be the main topic for
tonight but what other moves come to
mind besides d5 well I can actually do a
wide variety of things what else comes
to minds
yeah c5 is probably the most testing
variation against the f3 NIMS Oh
white is saying I want to control the
light squares with this move f3 and c5
actually attacks a dark square so as
always in chess you have to give
something to take something and so
because I wanted to take the light
squares against c5 I now have to give
the dark squares so my dark squares are
going to be weak in this opening
variation meanwhile I'll have a little
bit of a central advantage on the light
squares so I'll have slightly more space
and this is kind of the big imbalance
that the game is going to follow so if
you're looking for something to really
take out the f3 NIMS Oh see 5 is the
move for you and then ok I'll ask you to
try and find one more one more move that
that seems potentially good so we have
right now a couple classical ways of
approaching the center right just
occupying the center pushing the pawns
forward to challenge challenge white
Center maybe there is a more modern
approach that could be taken
what other natural moves are there it's
not really like a big you know a puzzle
where you have to try and find some
unique clever idea you just played
natural moves and quite often those are
correct early on in the opening so I
heard castles what else
nicely six so 96 I'll talk about first
the Smoove you actually want to be a
little bit careful with knights going in
front of the C pawn can be a little bit
misplaced sometimes because like I said
a lot of times you want to play the c5
move or even c6 to support the center
and this Knight could get in the way but
much more natural is to castle and this
is actually the the line that I favor
when I'm playing with the black pieces
here and it's kind of a funny line how
it's normally played is along these
lines and generally black ends up with
all those pieces on the back row white
gets the entire center and the way the
game goes
is black eventually starts attacking the
center with moves like this and white
tries to checkmate black and I think it
makes for a very fun game so all of this
is to say that even on move for the the
starting position of the f3 nib so black
has a ton of options which is why it's
so strange to me
when I play this in tournament chess
against weaker players and against even
like I said players over 2000 they
almost all exclusively play d5 which is
in my opinion the worst of these
variations for black this one kit
actually gives white quite a lot of
chances in the opening so I might be a
you know giving away all the secrets
here but I really don't think d5 is the
move people should be playing I really
like the c5 line and casas as well is
also very good but today my opponent
with the black pieces played a move that
was not any of those three options he
captured on c3 so what do you guys think
about this move any first impressions on
Bishop takes c3
and actually this is a move that a
couple people in the YouTube chat
suggested so my opponent was not alone
in thinking that this was a good move
and that might give you a hint
as to my opinion of the move yes yes
that's exactly right almost always in
this opening white ends up playing a
three forcing this bishop to make a
decision and then white wants to
recapture with with this beep on and so
by playing Bishop takes c3 you're
actually giving up a very very crucial
tempo it's giving me the opportunity to
not waste my time playing a3 myself and
because of that I can use this time to
do a lot more useful things than then
put a pawn on a three probably the
reason why my opponent was tempted to do
this is a lot of times in the nihms oh
wait tries to play a move like Queen c2
or move like Queen b3 and the point is
now let's say castles are something
now with a3 white sometimes wants to
recapture this with a piece keeping this
pawn on b2 and preserving that the
structure but really that's not even
ever it's not ever an idea in the f3
names oh we almost always take back with
the B pond and the reason is we want to
support our central pawn on d4 so Bishop
takes c3 is really just a
misunderstanding of this opening and so
this is the the first point I wanted to
make I know we're spending a lot of time
on move four but I think there's a lot
to be learned here just from the use of
these decisions so obviously my opponent
was not super familiar with the f3 NIM
so if he was familiar he wouldn't have
taken on c3 and so what should you do
when you're unfamiliar with an opening
what do you fall back on the basics
that's exactly right you go back to your
basic opening principles what are the
opening principles well they tell you to
control the center play a move like d5
or c5 they tell you to castle your king
or they tell you to develop your pieces
which in this case maybe that's why you
you fell you fell into knight c6 but
even a move like let's let's say b6
would be much better than Bishop takes
c3 and I think even nice e6 does I
better move them too should take c3 and
so this is really a point I want to
hammer home a lot of players get to a
point where they're like they kind of
just discount the opening principles
because they think they're too good for
them but really when you're unfamiliar
with the opening you should fall back on
principles because they lead you to the
correct moves like these three main
options are all following opening
principles to a tee but instead we see
Bishop takes c3 and B takes c3 my
opponent then plays d5 so now he is
controlling the center I continue with C
takes d5 and he takes d5 and now yet
let's see I found a way to make the
opening very very difficult for my
opponent already thanks to some an
inaccurate play on his part so try and
finds a very annoying in fact it might
not even be the best move but it is
quite annoying for black to deal with
that is true that is true
he took my only developed piece I get in
the back
g5 you mean yeah Bishop g5 isn't a bad
idea in this opening though it's it's
actually not as common as you might
expect usually we have no problem
playing this movie for and so you you
might think though you want to take off
this night because it's controlling this
important square but really this bishop
is going to be a lot more valuable than
this Knight and so we're not really
ready to bring this bishop all the way
out did you have any idea
a3 or other yeah that's actually
entirely right that's that's what I
played in the game as Bishop a3 so what
makes this move so annoying
it's preventing something right it
prevents castling of course you can't
castle through check and at this moment
in the game I was like well I guess he's
just never gonna Castle because it seems
really difficult to right and my
opponent did come up with a clever way
to to get castle but first I want to say
maybe better than playing Bishop a3 is
just to continue normally just develop
your pieces and the extra tempo but
we'll find will make itself useful just
by playing normally so as always playing
normally never a bad idea but in the
game I thought Bishop a3 made things a
little bit annoying so in the game black
played knight c6 I simply continue
development and then he plays 97 and so
this is how he chose to get castled and
it's it's actually still it's quite bad
for black here I think if you ask a
computer let's say it's it's only about
+1 but I think practically this is
already very very close to very
dangerous territory for black I think
black is close to losing already and
when I say that I don't mean we need to
go crazy and open things up and try to
kill him we just develop our pieces with
Bishop d3
black does get castled and I simply play
Knight e to my opponent plays rook e8
and now I have a question for you should
white play Knight g3 should White Castle
or none of the above should white play
something else or doesn't matter am i
just asking trick questions sometimes I
do that
this is actually an important one so you
can rule out the trick question option
metaphor seems good someone in the
YouTube chat says metaphor from Ervin's
Natasha wants me to play King f2o and
our vans been convinced no longer
champion championing championing Knight
f4 yeah that's the word what's wrong
with the basics so by basically you mean
castling so castling is definitely the
most natural move and you should always
follow opening principles unless you
have a good reason not to the thing is
there's a very very good reason not to
in this case and I'll give you a hint it
revolves around White's best minor piece
that minor piece being this Bishop
Bishop controls the entire board and
helps support our plan of playing efore
and will be a key attacker if we do get
efore to come through against this Kings
side so with that in mind what does
castles
what does castling allow black to do
here
yeah so I think Bishop f5 is actually a
bit of a mistake here because black or
white has a tactic can anybody find the
tactic but you're on the right track
Bishop f5 is a really good idea you want
to trade off this Bishop yeah yeah
Bishop e7 is a nice intermediate move
but then Queen takes to seven and sorry
I'm putting my foot in my mouth there if
Bishop takes here Queen takes c3 you're
actually not winning a piece thanks to
Rick f2 so white would be winning a
piece against Bishop f5 but the other
movie suggested Knight f5 I think is is
quite powerful here it makes a threat to
the e3 pawn in tandem with the rook
so defending it is not enough white will
still be able to capture and this would
force us to trade off for a beautiful
beautiful Bishop for that horrible
horrible night on e7 and we simply don't
want to allow that so this is why white
shouldn't castle here with that of Mines
the move I played was simply Knight g3
putting another attacker on this f5
square this prevents black from from
bringing any piece to f5 in the near
future and is more than enough to slow
down his development a move like Knight
f4 would actually be quite bad and the
reason for that is it's not keeping in
line with with our plan the point of the
f3 NIMS o which I guess I should make
this more clear I don't know if I've
I've said this obviously you're
controlling the e4 square but you're
controlling it for the purpose of
eventually breaking through in the
centre by playing efore yourself and so
night of 4 while this Knight looks nice
it attacks the D pawn it's near the king
it's not supporting this plan of playing
a floor so it's a bad move King f2
everybody loves to always like play when
they're not actually at the board but
castling is really nice castling is
powerful so I simply play a knight g3
controlling this f5 square in Bishop g7
and then okay before we move on one more
point about this knight g3 this is why
it's it's useful to spend time in the
opening you'll see players kind of rush
through the openings sometimes because
they think I'll just develop my pieces
and
everything will be fine but these kinds
of threats can be made very very early
on and they can have a huge impact on
the result of the game so it's important
to take your time and to notice things
like rook e8 which just looks like a
normal move is actually creating some
some threats that you have to account
for
so Knight g3 Bishop d7 and only now I
Castle now black is in a rather
unfortunate situation where it's very
very difficult to find a move to play it
seems like every move kind of just makes
this position worse maybe he'd like to
move this Knight out to g6 but really
what is it doing you might look at this
square and maybe this is the move he
should have played but you know I think
things are just awkward so the move he
came up with is after sorry after
castles whoops I skipped ahead I didn't
mean it after castles he played Queen c8
so what do you think his idea is with
Queen to ca I was asking myself this
question in the game as well
yeah that's exactly right I think this
is what he was thinking is he wanted
really to trade off some of these pieces
on f5 however what is wrong with this
idea what can I do here
Queen c2 yeah Queen c2 is actually a
pretty nice move but I wanted to play it
a little bit more more quickly yeah
nothing wrong with Queen c2 though yeah
yeah you simply play E for the time is
right note that it would be a mistake to
play move like Eve for here you don't
always want to do these things as as
soon as you can
first of all your king is still in the
center and this Knight isn't yet on its
ideal square but once you get the night
out and you get castled you're perfectly
ready you're totally fine to play this
movie for to play your pawn break one
reason I didn't want to put this Queen
on c2 is because after efore and takes
takes which is what was played in the
game it's sometimes very useful to have
this Queen on this diagonal to come out
in this direction that's true it's true
but pretty quickly you'll you'll see
you'll see what happens in the game in
the game my opponent played Knight g6
and now it's very safe to say that that
white is is completely winning this
central advantage with E 4 and d4
especially supported by this pawn on c3
it is just totally totally crushing with
that in mind how to continue there's
actually a lot of options here so just
throw out any ideas probably there at
they're all winning
paani five you said yeah that's that's
totally right ie five is a perfectly
fine move however you do have to be a
little bit cautious because black is
going to come to d5 and he's probably
aiming to to put some of these Knights
on f4 but that being said that you know
every everything is good here for white
oh I wasn't lying so now let me rephrase
the question how do you look the coolest
in your chess game what's the coolest
thing to do here it's not very cool to
just easily win you want to put some
Flair on it you know you've got some
Chess Club regulars standing by your
board they're all watching maybe like a
stir Sara Juan just came up the steps
and he's contemplating your position and
you look up and you see them and then
you play which move
a couple of people in YouTube have the
right idea but I won't give it away
don't you dare II that YouTube chechen
yeah
yeah that's exactly right rook takes f6
rook takes Knight you sacrifice the
exchange you impress all your friends
you get all the glory and this is
actually really really common motif in
this opening this knight in this pawn
together
really hold together black's entire
king's side and after rook takes f6 and
pawn takes f6 every square around the
King has been weakened this Knight no
longer controls this very nice square
for both the Queen in the knight this
pawn no longer controls any dark squares
around the King and this is this is
enough to kind of end the game I
continued with Knight h5 very very
natural you just attack this pawn queen
d8 was this choice and now there's no
rush you just bring the rest of your
pieces into the game Queen f3 still
piling up against this f6 pawn rook e6
was his attempts defending laterally and
now I actually did something rather mean
I played Queen III the point being I
want to go give checkmate to solve this
problem
he plays King h8 but now simply you
wreck f1 and this is this is just as
easy as Cheska's you bring your pieces
into the game and then eventually your
opponent kind of crumbles bishop c8 was
the only move he could come up with I
remember there was some reason why he
played this move but for the life of me
I can't I can't remember what that
reason is at the moment I played a 5 in
order to really break through on this f6
square after takes rook takes f7 the the
game is nearing its end pawn takes Queen
h6 Queen g8 and now rook g7 is enough to
end the game
and this is this is how the game
actually went rook e1 check King f2 he
gives a very sneaky long check but I can
simply take this rook and after a couple
more checks the the game is over after
rook age 7 9 8 7 in Queen g7 mate
so I kind of skipped through the fun bit
at the end of the game but that last
part wasn't too instructive black was
was simply lost the Kings side was
fractured all you have to do is bring
your pieces into the game and in the
rest is history but any questions about
the key part of this game the key part
is actually this opening this is where
the entire game was decided so does
everybody understand how black went
wrong okay we'll keep it in mind because
we're about to see it over and over and
over again because this is how all of my
games in the f green enzo go so if you
want free wins this is the way to do it
up next on our victims list is Jason
Zhao and this was actually a rapid game
here at the club and one of the Friday
pods and let's let's just get into it
d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight c3 Bishop b4
and once again f3 Jason played d5 which
is a much better move than Bishop takes
c3 I played a3 now and you can kind of
really see that the difference
Bishop takes pawn takes Jason got
castled and I will say a very
respectable line is to play C 5 here and
after tix
you can play pawn takes but a much
better line for black I think is to play
Knight takes and I won't go into this
this type of theory but I did want to
mention that this option exists for
black instead though we see castles and
after takes no black has to play pawn
takes and we play very very similarly to
to what we saw last game simply III
we're gonna develop our pieces get
castled expand in the center and try to
checkmate the King Bishop f5 was his
choice here however and so what is the
point of this move if you've if you were
paying attention last game it should be
pretty pretty clear what does black want
to do here
preventing you for not quite not quite I
mean yes but but not quite if you
remember this was this was a move Luke
II was really really struggling to play
in the previous game and why was it
gonna be so preferable for him if he
could play Bishop f5
yeah it's exactly right the best square
for this bishop by far is Bishop d3 and
this is a very very powerful Bishop and
if black can get this Bishop off the
board his position is actually going to
be much much better than it was before
so with that in mind how can how can you
play here with the white pieces let me
remind myself what I did okay
how can you play to try to take
advantage of this bishop coming to f5 so
early
there's a couple things you can do G for
well I think if we check a database yeah
G for is actually the very very common
idea a lot of times they start with
ninety two and then after some move
let's say C five now I think yeah G for
by far is the most common idea and this
has been played a ton by a lot of very
very strong players and the point is
you're actually gonna put this Bishop on
g2 instead of d3 and you're still gonna
push in the center with E for now you're
just gonna do all of it with a pawn on
g4 just just for fun and this is
actually the the main way of playing
against this but in the game I did start
with 92 and after rook e8 I chose kind
of a simpler approach to this game I
didn't want to play g4 for whatever
reason I just wasn't feeling up to it on
the night of and so the move I chose was
Knight g3 and it's a very similar idea
to g4 meaning I'm attacking the bishop
and the point is I'm just kind of
gaining a tempo with this move my knight
was coming to g3 anyways and now my
opponent has to spend a tempo moving
this bishop before I allow him to trade
it off bishop g6 was this choice and now
I do just play Bishop d3 and take stakes
and so I will say that g4 is a better
way of playing for white here but this
is a simple way of playing and we'll see
it kind of worked out in the game night
be d7 was my opponent's choice and this
move I'm actually going to call a slight
mistake and the reason for that is this
Knight has no future from d7 thus Knight
really belongs on c6 and I'll give a
gold star to anybody who can tell me why
why I should this Knight be on c6
and for hints I will tell you it
prevents efore somehow not directly but
it helps to prevent you for it doesn't
prevent it forever
but it does help
someone in YouTube says this night
should go tonight i-5 to c4 to them I
would say well what's different about
Knight b6 to c4 I don't know
see if someone in YouTube does have it
ts Jo gets the gold star the night
belongs on c6 but the trick in my and my
phrasing was that this pond should be on
c5 first
now let's say we castle and now knight
c6 and this is how blacks should be
playing to prevent white from pushing e4
white will always or almost always have
enough support from his pieces with this
pawn on f3 to support the e4 pawn but by
playing efore we actually leave this D
pawn behind and this is quite often how
black gets around in this efore push
which can be quite quite powerful it's
by putting pressure on d4 for example if
we just calculate here for a second
we'll see that we actually don't have
enough support to play e4 just yet
because the D pawn would hang and so
this makes life White's life a lot more
difficult you have to support this eat
this D pawn by playing some unnatural
moves maybe even like a Bishop b2 which
doesn't seem quite quite natural right
to put the Bishop on this blocked off
diagonal and so this is how blacks
should be playing instead though we see
Knight bd7 and while this develops it
doesn't develop with a purpose and
that's really important it's something
I've said before okay so we see King
side castles c6 and with that in mind
what I just talked about why a c6 bad
move
what doesn't it do it doesn't put
pressure on d4 and so now that I've been
given free rein to do whatever I want I
could play E for immediately if I wanted
to instead though I prepared it a bit
more I played this move rook a to with
the classic idea of bringing the rook to
the center one of one of these central
squares to support the center even
further Knight b6 was this choice and
now I do continue with with E for o and
actually though okay I couldn't play e4
here I remembered now there is a trick
what would black do if if I played efore
and we went into this line I always got
to avoid these these tricky tricky moves
there is a tactic here in ninety five is
totally right we we hit the Queen we hit
efore and due to the pin we can't
capture this Knight
so I would actually just be losing upon
which is why rook a to prepares rookie
tune to support this pawn a little
further
of course after 96-95 is no longer
possible so I can play e4 with country
my opponent brings this Knight to c4 but
I hope everybody can see that this night
on c4 well maybe we've been told
classically Knights on c4 are very
powerful they control a lot of squares
in the Queen side it's simply irrelevant
to the game and this Knight does nothing
to help this King it does nothing to
help the center controlling the squares
irrelevant squares already controlled by
this pawn quite easily and so this night
ends up just being out of the game and
due to that I think white is simply
winning in this position that's it's
plus two its move 15 and it's plus two
which is not bad I played rookie to just
bringing the rook into the center Knight
d7 and now F for taking advantage of the
fact that if black captures he leaves
this this night behind otherwise you
know it'd be bad to allow black to kind
of separate our puns like this we see B
5 so now black is threatening to take on
e4 and so I play e5
and it's it's pretty clear that this is
this has gone pretty wrong for for black
here this night's completely out of the
game this rooks also slightly shut out
and it was like f5 and f6 are are going
to come with devastating effect we see 9
f8 is my opponents try simply f5 you
play very very simple moves a5 came from
my opponent I played rook f4 I just want
to come kill the king f6 was his
attempts to try and prevent me from
playing f6 myself simply rook g4 takes
and now Knight h5 and in the end is near
everything is collapsing on this g7 pawn
rook a 7 was played it's now +8 by the
way Queen g3 g6
takes takes and then alright whoops once
again when win with style everybody win
with style how can you win with style
here
rook takes g6 I love it
Knight takes g6 Queen takes g6 King h8
alright and now simply every move is
winning you get to play this beautiful
little rook sacrifice and in the game I
played Bishop g5 and Riki six was his
attempt to try to keep the game going
of course I was threatening his Queen he
tries to threaten my queen and if I were
to take this truck he would take my
bishop but simply Knight f6 is is very
very strong and this hurts to look at so
I won't make you look at it too much
longer
rookie 7 Queen h6 check rook h7 Knight
takes rook takes and now Bishop f6 check
the meanest of the moves of course I
could take here and take here and be up
a full ruck but Bishop f6 check really
truly a disgusting move and hear my
opponent resigned the point is after
King g8 I can give this check and now
pick up the Queen so that's another like
30 some move game in the in the f3 NIM
so are we starting to identify some some
patterns here Luke you really gave me
everything I wanted he took on c3 on his
own giving me extra time in this game my
opponent put up a much stronger
resistance but still this plan with E 4
is is quite quite strong and unless
black plays more actively on the Queen
side this is just this is how the games
go this is just how it happens alright
any questions about this game in
particular or anything we've we've
talked about so far anybody is starting
to make sense we're recognizing the
patterns alright let's move on to fun
game number 3 in true chess player style
I had saved this game I did not save my
opponent's name but I did save their
rating so we're all just numbers in the
end I guess but see my opponent was
around 20 170 rated when we played this
game I have no idea who my opponent was
I do know who I was though I was the
white player but once again we're in the
f3 NIMS Oh once again my opponent played
a slightly strange move here knight c6
so we actually are gonna get a chance to
talk about this one and this is a little
bit of a different way of playing for
the black player I think we looked
enough at these d5 things let's let's
take a look at what happens when they
play a little bit differently so I
continue degree take sticks now my
opponent plays d6 so this is a little
bit more of a classical approach to
nineveh type structures
you
you
okay let's talk about that sound should
be back so what I might I have been
refraining from playing this move pawn
to e4 it blocks my Bishop coming out
that's actually very very close to
exactly the right answer
yeah it's it's a very good point
obviously in the other games I was
putting Eve for but then almost gave me
two days after I was able to play the
CEPA five move so what it really as what
I was blocking in this this trip forever
but in this case after white plays d4
what move is black gonna look to respond
with
yeah that's exactly right Eve five not
my puns are gonna be locked on these
light squares and maybe even this this
pawn on d4 is gonna be a bit of a
weakness so you do have to be a little
cautious here now this position is
totally playable for white I'm not
saying it's not but in the game I didn't
really want to commit to this just yet
so III instead my opponent still plays
a5 and now I get to bring my bishop here
and this diagonal is is gonna stay open
for the moment Queen e7 was my
opponent's choice
I simply continue development with 92
Knight a five castles and now now b6 so
here I made a decision and that decision
was to capture this knight on f6 and
this wasn't actually the best move for
white these the Starks squared Bishop is
a pretty powerful piece and giving it up
for the night isn't quite right
much better instead let's see I think is
to play rather simply can play a move
like rook b1 just improve your pieces
start thinking about moves like efore
and eventually f4 to break open the
center and just not commit to giving up
this bishop just yet but let's roll with
it Bishop takes f6 Queen f6 and now what
is the natural follow-up to to taking on
f6 I did have kind of a purpose behind
it there was a reason I wanted to play
Bishop f6 before before this move what's
the natural follow up
93 okay so in the previous lecture this
93 has been has been the follow-up
because we wanted to prevent Bishop f5
right and if Bishop f5 was possible
after the move that I okay so let's say
I played like a nothing move Bishop f5
is possible here but Bishop a6 might
even be stronger just hitting this e4
pawn and looking to trade off the
bishops via c4 rather than a f5 so I
have to do something a little more
active rather than Knight g3 this okay
so I will say while you guys are
thinking the ideas here while they look
pretty different than the last games we
looked at it's still all about opening
up these files for the rooks opening up
or keeping open this diagonal and
finding ways to bring the pieces into
the game so in the previous game games
that was done via e4 and then e 5 and
then pushing this pawn forward in this
game we still want to open things up but
it's gonna be a little bit different see
ya Brian yeah f4 is entirely right
that's what I played in the game like I
said you're just looking for ways to
open up the position and by threatening
pawn takes pawn you're trying to get
this rook into the game and I think this
is actually pretty nice for white yes
that's exactly right um if I had played
f4 here I was a little concerned about
this movie 4 and while I could still
capture this and he would be forced to
capture back with the pawn otherwise I
could take here I didn't want to allow
my opponent to kind of shove this pawn
in my face especially with the C pawn
hanging so this is why I had to take on
f6 this also kind of increases the power
of f4 by putting the Queen opposite the
rook but let's continue Queen e7 was my
opponent's choice trying to step out of
everything and now of course I want to
open things up so I take on e5 no reason
not to pawn takes e5 and now I do
continue with this move Knight g3 like I
said it's it's all about opening
up files and diagonals and keeping them
open in this f3 and Enzo its Knight g3
still prevents this movie for from black
which would block out my bishop my
opponent plays g6 the point being he
wants to keep this night out of these
annoying squares f5 and h5 continue with
Queen f3 and my opponent plays Bishop a6
and this is a key moment in the game
there's actually only one move that
keeps an advantage for white here only
one move on the entire chessboard to
keep an advantage blacks idea is very
very simple he wants to take the c4 pawn
and now I've been saying all along the
whole point is to open up diagonals and
and files and so that's the idea behind
this move how can we continue to open up
this Kings side and get at the black
King I'll give you some time Queen f6 so
that that's one idea I'm gonna let some
ideas come in then all I'll talk about
them in order so Queen f6 is one idea
like I said this is this is a tough one
so I'll give you some time
the YouTube chat has gone quiet okay
they have they have some ideas some very
good ideas night f5 so night f5 is the
move that I played and this is actually
the only move to keep an advantage Queen
f6 is actually not really keeping in
line with with our ideas here you might
be looking to do one of these sacrifices
but by allowing this trade of Queens
you're really giving up too much in
things like Bishop takes c4 are gonna
come too quickly for any sacrifices to
be to be useful so when you're trying to
attack like this trading Queens not
always the best idea especially when
your opponent has a huge structural edge
on you this this weakness on c4 is is a
huge problem so the best move
the only good move for white is is
Knight f5 and I'm still to this day
years later quite happy with myself for
playing but now I get to talk about it
on the Internet which is great my
opponent rose to the challenge and
captured this Knight of course he kind
of has to he's kind of forced to capture
this attacking both this Queen and this
pawn there's no real good way to solve
both threats if you play Queen g5 does
anybody see a winning move here for
white there is one but can you see it
yes simply h4 removes the defender from
the h6 pawn and if Queen h5 do we take
this Queen no good answer but why not
what do we do instead this is a fun 197
yet this move is is good the funniest
move though and I think the best move is
g4 and this Queen is locked in a deadly
corridor of pawns and there's no escape
this Knight very useful defends h4 okay
so not Queen g5 instead pawn takes
Knight the only real move worth
considering Queen takes f5 obviously I
want to checkmate my opponent my
opponent played the only move f6
defending laterally and now how do we
continue the attack we're down a full
piece how do we continue the attack yeah
exactly
you just bring more pieces into the game
rook f3 you play very natural chess you
don't have to panic because you gave up
a piece you just have to play good
natural chess a huge mistake would be
playing a move like like Queen g6 check
this is simply helping your opponent by
giving him time to use his Queen to
defend his King so Rick f3 instead my
opponent rises to the challenge again
plays Bishop takes c4 and this was
actually his his fatal mistake here he
had to continue defending his King with
a little bit more urgency right you
don't have time here to be grabbing this
pawn he was probably thinking he was
grabbing this pawn and defending his
king by by trying to trade off these
bishops and control some of these
squares but the fact of the position is
it doesn't do enough so what's a better
defensive move for black I will ask
before we move on
how can he kind of start a mad dash with
with the king to escape all of this
horrible horrible business work f7 is
totally right and give yourself a little
escape route use this rook as a blocker
in front of your king this this really
helps helps black out here that being
said I think white is actually still
doing doing quite well I don't have all
the variations in front of me but some
things like rook g3 and King f8 and
Queen g6 are our good ideas correct g7
there's always moves like Queen h6 to
look out for and why it's gonna have a
lot of compensation for the piece it's
it's gonna be quite good still instead
though we see Bishop takes c4 of course
I continue with the check no I don't
continue with the check because I'm very
very smart
so Bishop e4 is a nice in-between move
hitting this rook and actually defending
the d5 square four moves like pawn to d5
to come into play later we see rook a d8
now I do give this check and after King
h8 hold on yeah King h8 I do want to
mention nevermind I was deciding if I
wanted to show a tactic here or later
I'll show it later so King h8 first I
played very very naturally rook g6 hits
an h6 pawn this rook comes to h7 trying
to defend along the seventh rank a
little bit simply reacting stage six is
enough King to g8 in our rook g6 king f7
and how does white win from this
position how do you do it
where's the wind
what was that d5 it's a good idea but
not quite I'll get to Eunice I think
you've got it I'll get to you in a
second
d5 doesn't do enough it's it's more
forcing than d5 yeah someone in YouTube
has it as well yeah Queen h5 no not
Queen h5 got to be more forcing all
right Brian what's what's the move rook
g7 is absolutely right
rook g7 check putting the rook on pre or
on priests to the king if the King runs
to e8 of course there is rook takes
Queen winning enough material to justify
all your sacrifices and if King takes
rook
of course Queen h7 not Queen g6 but
Queen h7 with a nice checkmate
using blacks pieces against him as well
as this bishop and that is is how this
game should have ended and said though
my opponent was very mean and made me
play on up a queen and the game
continued for a few more moves and
eventually we got here and this is this
is forced to me well done though rook g7
a favorite tactic of mine to win a game
so once again the f3 names O is all
about opening up these lines opening up
these files and trying to use this in
the centre to your advantage and that's
not unique to the f3 NIMS oh that can be
applied to pretty much any opening you
play you want to open up lines for your
pieces especially on the side of your
board on the side of the board where you
have an advantage and in that case this
is the King's side for white you just
want to make the most of your pieces and
that's what I did in this game that's
what I did in those first two games as
well and and that's all you have to do
if you want to play the f3 NIMS Oh like
a pro I think that's going to be the
last game I go over for the night we do
have a little bit of time left over
any questions about the F train Enzo in
general any anything about the plans for
either side yeah so it's not a bad
response let's go back to this the
station this outer shell game this one
you played d5 and this is by far the
most popular response to f3 it's d5 it
makes sense right you control efore but
the reason I don't like it for black is
because white kind of has this this
cookie cutter plan where if you don't
play the most accurately it's very
simple for white to play I put my bishop
on d3 I put my knight on g 3i castle
I play e4 I win the game I've had dozens
of games go like this and this is why
you have to really know your stuff if
you're gonna play like this with black I
will say in in my memory I don't know if
I've lost any games in this line over
the board except to one player that
player being daro Schwartz the almost
2700 rated chess player so yeah he was
kind enough to show me how this this
opening should be played and I will say
if you do want to play this opening you
should really play whoops this move if
my mouse will allow it c5 here putting
pressure on this d4 pawn this is
something that daro did this is
something that you should do as well you
need this pressure on d4 in order for
this opening to work at all and I will
say the reason that this opening is
playable for black is not just because
of this pressure on d4 but because black
has a very nice way to actually trade
off these bishops so if you do want to
play this line with the black pieces in
in this manner keep in mind you don't
want to develop this knight right away
you want to get castled and play b6 and
as soon as you can you can trade this
bishop not via f5 but via this a6 square
and this is the kind of prescribed way
of ax
playing this d5 system with black now I
don't think this has ever been played
against me over the board this this line
specifically daro did something else
that is also very combative but if you
do want to play like this with black
this is this is how it should be done
but even this I I do I do
quite favor for white okay any other
questions all right I think I'm going to
call the lecture here then once again
this has been the f3 NIMS oh and what
you shouldn't do with black and what you
should do with white so thank you guys
so much for joining me tonight this has
been the road to 2000 and I'll see you
guys next week
you
[Music]
you